hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i
put a video out last week and said that
i was going to move into somebody's
house
and live with somebody for a week and
help them become financially free
now i am going to do that still and for
those people that did videos thank you
so much i'm gonna be in touch with you
this week okay
i'm gonna be in touch with every single
person that did a video i have been in
touch with some of you already
however i was overwhelmed with comments
from people saying things like
samuel i don't want you to live with me
i want to come and live with you
people are saying they want to come into
my house they want to shadow me they
want to be learned
trained for me they want to learn from
me and you know some people also saying
stuff like samuel you know it's not
practical for you to come to my house
um and different things like that so
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
i'm still gonna move into someone's
house that's still happening that's
still completely on the table
but i decided to not take one person by
the way there was only like 25 people
that did a video
that's how few people take action which
is fine but
i'm not going to tell one person for
this challenge i'm going to take 10
people 10 people and i'm gonna have
next month month of november i'm going
to take 10 people
and i'm going to have them come down to
my house 10 people
and i'm going to work with 10 people
throughout the whole month of november
completely free no charge
i'm going to train them i'm going to
give them all of my training
and i'm going to work with them on
challenges no charge
the only thing you need to pay for is
like you've done your food and petrol
and things like that
zero charge i'm going to take 10 people
i
want to be taking the 10 people that are
hungry that have drive
that have passion that's what i'm
looking for not money i don't want you
cannot pay for this
you cannot pay to come down to my house
and be trained
for a month like this you can't pay now
during the month of november
those 10 people i'm going to be i'm
going to be working with them
but i'm going to be wanting to choose
the person who is the hungriest
the hungriest person and the hungriest
person
is going to get a 12 month program where
i'm going to walk with them and journey
with them for 12 months
and if you want that person i'll live
with you for a week as well i mean i'll
move into your house i'm good
i'm good so if you want to come you want
to work with me throughout the month of
november
you want one of the 10 people all you
need to do
is fill in the application form below
there's no taxes
there's no strings attached it's
completely free just fill the form in
below
but you've got to be hungry i'm only
going to be taking 10 people that are
hungry that are prepared to do whatever
it takes
and those 10 people i'm going to put
through a series of training programs
you're going to come down to my house
i'll show you around you'll have
different challenges
i'll be giving you exercises each week
and every week i'm gonna be doing
eviction style
okay i'm gonna be i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be uh evicting people every week
and then the person that is still
standing at the end of
november i'm gonna work with for a whole
year journey with
move into the house do a financial
freedom challenge with them partner with
them
but the whole 10 people are going to
receive top-notch world-class training
to help them become financially free and
property this is going to be
life-changing groundbreaking
completely free all you need to do fill
the form in below
and when we're looking at your form
we'll want to see that you smash the
like button and that you dropped a nice
comment to this video too
so drop a nice comment smash the like
button make sure you subscribe
and fill the application form in
below it's free i want to work with you
i'll be choosing
ten people not one person this isn't
only one no
ten people geez there'll probably be
only a hundred or two that fill in the
application form
so you just fill that in make sure
you're hungry make sure you're free next
month
let's work together man come round my
house let's do this no
charge baby no charge fill it in